yeah yeah i i feel like the platform has
changed a lot since
we started growing you could get away
with doing the parts before yeah
you can't do video parts now unless you
have like a massive series that people
are really waiting
right yeah yeah yeah we say parts of our
[ __ ] trash taste is part yeah
we've literally put numbers on each of
them that's just for ease isn't it to
keep track of it yeah i mean it's it's
kind of like i mean
it's past but you can enjoy each part i
mean it's i don't even call it a part
it's an episode number right
and you can enjoy each episode by itself
and then there are also people who are
just like are like totally ingrained in
like the trash taste
lore whatever the [ __ ] that is like
i go onto our subreddit sometimes and
i'm just like man
the amount the amount of layers that new
like viewers would have to understand
just to get this one meme is [ __ ]
ridiculous we literally have
a chronological order and like a [ __ ]
like law order
yeah no it's it's watching order and
chronicles
because like the trash tastes law like
watching our subreddit
goes beyond just our channel now and
just it's just like everyone we've ever
interacted with is now part of the trash
taste lore
it's hilarious i find it like i find it
impressive how people have just like
been able to create this like
because it's not even like it's not even
logically laid out people just have this
unwritten understanding that
okay yeah this is but this is part of
the trash taste lawn part of the trash
taste group the only other like group
i've seen this dedicated is like people
who are like into the gnosis
right it's like this is like wow just
call me out joey call me out like that
it's the face it's the it's the fate
yeah it's it's like it's
they're [ __ ] pulling it from like
literally nowhere that has
anything to do with anything being like
well i mean god did say this thing
on this like tiny like youtubers podcast
like
six years ago yeah i'm pretty sure this
has a connection
somewhere to one of these episodes right
it's it's weird man it feels like the
first time on
youtube where people like actively care
about what i'm doing
like does that sound strange like before
i just felt like no one gave a [ __ ] what
i was up to right yeah just do my own
thing
yeah now i feel like people actually
actually like watch when i do something
like whoa this is weird well that's the
thing it's like i've i've noticed that
whenever i go into the subreddit it's
like
half of these posts have nothing to do
with the actual trash taste episodes and
it's like it's either drawn from like
someone's twitter or someone's twitch or
a guest's twitter or a guest twitch it's
like
or like a friend of one of the hosts
yeah
what i'm just gonna cool though i i mean
i i'm we're not saying this is a bad
thing
i'm just like i just find it really
interesting that yeah became like that i
know
what i find really interesting that
people are able to follow along
with this where there's even though
there's like there's no [ __ ] coherent
watch order
you know like we've gone to the point
where you can watch every
episode of trash taste and still not
understand everything going on in the
subreddit right because then you have to
follow our content
and follow other people's content other
people's twitter and i'm just like
god [ __ ] down man respect to you
i'm just so confused i'm i'm on this
podcast and i don't know though
i i can't keep up with the
i don't know [ __ ] don't know what's
canon and what's not anymore
like what is canon what is not canon um
it's just
i i i just view it as one of the people
in like the [ __ ] law and i'm just
like
damn man what is going on right i guess
i did say or do that
i don't know everyone should call me a
vtuber simp now so that's all they call
me now
yeah that's been the that's been the hot
meme we just dated this
episode again by just saying that right
now the big hot meme on the trash today
subreddit is connor
making every viewer interacts with into
a connoisseur
essentially which is hilarious because
you were the i've seen this [ __ ]
screenshot
everywhere whenever someone mentions
that like you're the youtuber soon now
being like
this is one screenshot that just says i
don't understand v2
i i still kind of don't like meanwhile
every youtuber is like well i understand